[Music]
collecting hay samples and having them
analyzed are important steps in
understanding if your forage program
meets the nutritional needs of livestock
a forged analysis provides crucial
information on nutritional value of
stored forages such as hay and helps
producers be more efficient in their
feed resource decision making
equipment required for collecting a hay
sample includes a forage probe a mixing
bucket and sample bags each county
extension office has a forage probe that
can be used to collect samples on a farm
the forage probe is operated using an
electric drill
hay samples can be collected following
baling if the bales are to be stored in
a barn or near the time of feeding
allow enough time for test results to be
returned to determine if supplemental
feeds are needed a two to three week
window is recommended for planning a
sample submission and return
test each lot of forge separately a lot
is defined as hay that was harvested at
the same time out of the same field and
under the same conditions
for example if you had four hay cuttings
during the season collect a
representative sample from each cutting
use a hay probe to collect 15 to 20 core
samples from individual bales within
each lot
insert the probe into the bale at a 90
degree angle
for a round bale insert the probe into
the curved side of the bale and sample
towards the center for a square bill
insert the probe into the center of the
end of the bale
remove the probe by reversing the
direction of the drill
detach the probe from the drill and
empty the sample into a bucket
after sampling a complete lot 15 to 20
core samples thoroughly mix the samples
in the bucket and place a subsample in a
one quart plastic bag the bag should be
at least half full
label each sample obtain an analysis
form and submit the sample and the form
to a certified forage testing laboratory
near you
the laboratory will send you a summary
report with information on the
nutritional value of the sample
this report can then be used to help
create a supplementation plan for your
livestock
you can also work with your local animal
science and forage regional extension
agent or county extension office to
submit a sample for analysis
we are here to help you build great
management practices for your operation
for more information on forms and
laboratory locations visit the alabama
extension website
you